Chris Gore, Founder/Owner of
FilmThreat/Author/Filmmaker: It has
everything Hollywood movies wish they had.
Film Courage: Today we have another quote
here. We've done this with you in the past.
We're wondering if you can read this
quote? Not sure you know who it is?
Chris: Let's see if I can figure it out. Okay…I
feel like I'm on a game show. [Chris reads quote]
I am a filmmaker. My job is to make films. When
something excites you, a story or characterization
you immediately forget about everything else.
You only think how to make a movie out of it. The
economics come only later. You shouldn't let money
dictate the kind of films you should make. Well I
really love that statement. I'm not exactly sure
who wrote it but I love that. I think there's a
couple of things. It's unfortunate that filmmaking
is the most expensive art form. Even if you make a
film on your iPhone at some point you're going
to have to do a professional sound mix you're
going to have to use color correction you're going
to have to spend some money to market the film
right so even movies at a low budget level money
is sort of the unspoken producer of every movie
that's why when you see the movies with the
highest budgets many times they appeal to everyone
and no one and don't exactly leave leave you with
any sort of lasting impression but I think money
is always the unspoken producer and in addition
money is for many beginning filmmakers an excuse
to not make a movie so I feel like you need to
kind of set all those excuses aside find out what
your Baseline level budget is to tell a story
and if there's a way to do it leap right in but
now you have to tell me who said this I don't
know speaking of leap thinking of the dancing
scene that would be S. S. Rajamouli wow yeah S.
S. Rajamouli said that wow that's fantastic he I'm
become a quick fan of S. S. Rajamouli he directed
a film called RRR which is a Tollywood film
it's it's really interesting in India they
really have competing film Industries they
have Bollywood which many people are familiar
with Bollywood and Associate most of Indian
Cinema with Bollywood but there's also
Tollywood and there I think that the
rivalry between the two industries is actually
made for better films and I will say I discovered
RRR when it was number three at the box
office the weekend that the Batman opened
and I found that really strange how is it that
the weekend that this biggest superhero movie
Robert Pattinson is the Batman that this movie
RRR suddenly is Unleashed in the United States
and I went to see it on a whim based on a
recommendation from a friend and noticing
like how did this film and the film just
blew my mind three hour epic very Loosely
based on two historical figures and it has
everything Hollywood movies wish they had today
just compelling instantly likable characters
it very much felt like an old style Hollywood
movie a mix of yes there are dance numbers there's
also romance and humor action there's heroism acts
of self-sacrifice I don't know that Hollywood
can make a film like RR and it's it's really
disappointing to me oddly enough RRR is the I
believe the highest budget movie ever to come from
India at 75 million dollars and it's it's really
quite an achievement when you see the film I would
have thought it would be it would have been in the
hundreds of millions of dollars to make this movie
but the fact that it's 75 million
dollars and so epic in scale
there's a scene in at the near the
beginning of the film in the First Act
character named Ram who is an officer at
an outpost it's being protested and it's
an action sequence where Ram is sort of set on a
mission to to grab a perpetrator who threw a rock
he goes to try to track down this perpetrator it's
an epic action scene you can't believe I mean it's
just something on a scale we've never seen I
was shocked to learn that they took almost 30
days to shoot that scene with 20 000 extras
not digital effects twenty thousand extras
so the achievement of this film is so
remarkable and it makes me sad that like
hey Hollywood can't compete with this and
I do see when you go to your local Cinema
wherever your local movie theater is you're seeing
more and more not necessarily your Hollywood movie
but anime you're seeing Spanish language films
Indian films I mean at the AMC theaters that I
go to in Southern California there is at least a
new Indian movie every month sometimes two a month
I personally love that because I've always enjoyed
world cinema has I I've always enjoyed it but this
film is something special one interesting
thing that I would point out about RRR
is Americans reaction to this movie everyone I
know that has seen it has really loved it but
what I find interesting is we live at a time
where politics is infused into nearly every
art form comic books writing movies
television it's I could use a break frankly
from being lectured to no one likes to be
lectured to and this film does not do that
but there are thematically some interesting
things that are opposing in it and I'm really
surprised that that I've never seen anyone
point this out about RRR on the one hand
the villains of the film are
the colonizers the British
the Sun never sets on the British Empires what
they say and there's a character governor Scott
in in RRR that is I mean he is a villain right
out of a Star Wars movie with the British accent
and whatnot so the white Colonial Invaders of
India are the bad people now that is a political
messaging it's also a real historical thing that
happened okay so it's not like it's a message but
that's something that would appeal
to one side of the political aisle
would be hey the colonizers are the baddies
in this movie in addition in the same movie
there is also a thread about guns and owning a
gun and the correct use of a gun responsible use
of a weapon will lead to Freedom the character Ram
who I mentioned earlier you get a flashback in the
second half of the film with young Ram and his
father and he's teaching him about the value of
a bullet the value of a bullet being worth more
than the life of an Indian and how that kind of
plays through he tells them the value of bullet
what it can do responsible gun use you see sort
of training an army to to basically fight their
way to freedom from the British colonizers
so on the one hand you have a movie that's very
anti-colonizer that is also very pro-second
Amendment you could look at it that way I don't
think I've seen a movie I can't even think of a
film that contains if you've seen the movie RRR as
many times as I have you'll notice it two opposing
sides of the political aisle in terms of messaging
one being anti-colonizer another one being pro-gun
I don't know that S. S. Rajamouli intended it
to be that way I don't believe he's lecturing
in any portion of the film at all I think
it's all organic to the story I just find it
fascinating that not one person has pointed this
out that's interesting I hadn't even thought of
it I'm referring back to the scene that you're
talking about and there's also just to keep it
lighter there's friendship there's romance
there's amazing dance sequences and then
there's these animals right animals all digitally
the animals are all digitally created right but
also Ram's Mission which his sort of his his
family is decimated and murdered by the the
colonizers right by the British the British
soldiers wipe out his family and his tribe
nearly everyone in his tribe and then he grows
up and he's on a mission to get the guns because
guns will lead to freedom and if I mean India
was not United as a country at the time this
for a historical frame of reference the story
the story of our art takes place in the 1920s
it's also based on two real historical figures
and imagines if they had met right they never
actually didn't meet but but the film kind of is
is definitely I would call it historical fantasy
but you the India was not United as a country
it was groups of tribes the British colonizers
coming in kind of helped unite the people
the the Ram's mission is his whole mission
is to get weapons and then deliver them to his
tribes so they can fight for their freedom and
at least fight on an even playing field with
the British having guns and them having guns so
these are sensitive things to think about and talk
about because we live at a time where even if you
reveal even a hint at what your politics might be
it could be a death sentence for a career which
is sad to me it's sad that we can't have open
and honest conversations about a whole number
of issues I would love to be able to do that
but it's funny that this wildly successful very
mainstream and entertaining almost a tip of the
hat to old Hollywood film RRR has woven into it
some messages you could read read in that are
that are that are right in the middle of the
Divide of where people are right now in the
United States and are they on two different
religious spectrums as well in the film no they
don't not so much I mean the film does deal with
that but what I love about S. S. Rajamouli
as a filmmaker he was asked in an interview
or the interviewer asked him said hey have you
thought about doing a Marvel movie you should
based on the action in RRR you
should be making a Marvel movie
and S. S. Rajamouli said I have no interest in
doing a Marvel movie I don't want to do that and
he wants to keep his focus on telling stories from
Indian history and Indian mysticism fables and I
think that that is why I so admire SS Rajmouil is
a filmmaker because he wants to stick to his roots
and I think that that's incredibly admirable
did you expect to love the movie going in
I didn't know I didn't know what to expect
about RR when I went in to see it I just
thought well okay it's three hours I
know I'm going to have to take a break
at some point there's going to be an
intermission whether there is one or not
but I just fell in love with it because because it
reminded me of a type of movie that Hollywood used
to make which wasn't any genre you could easily
just say well RRR is an action movie it's not
just that it's also a historical fantasy it's also
a love story in fact there are two love stories
maybe three if you encount if you count
the friendship between beam and Ram
so it really is in my top probably top
five if not top three movies of the year
and it should give Hollywood pause to see how
successful this film is internationally how it's
beloved by anyone that sees it if there's a way to
see RRR in a movie theater I strongly recommend it
I've seen it in the theater four times I'm
actually going to see it for a fifth time in the
theater and when you see this movie it's like a
celebration I haven't seen an audience react this
way to a film in a theater since the very end of
Avengers end game that sort of swell of you don't
want to just clap you want to stand up and applaud
you want to scream for joy I mean I can think of
times in the past where I've screamed at a movie
theater applauded for Joy but I haven't done that
I haven't done that with a Hollywood film probably
since that scene and end game the portals scene
which is the the very end of the film I thought
that was like that was the combination of 10 years
of Marvel movies telling effectively what turned
out to be one story leading to that epic battle
Nothing Compares except for the film RRR seeing
it in the theater is for me if it's playing I'm
going to go I'm just so taken with this film
and I think there's so much there's so much to
learn from it and I really hope that Hollywood
learns the lesson of please stop the lecturing
tell audiences a story that they can be engaged
with characters that you fall in love with
and I think really that formula is fairly simple
I don't I don't know where we got to this place
where we felt it necessary to infuse all of
our entertainment with with with some sort
of lecturing it's just you just don't need
it and it's Tollywood you said Tollywood yes
there yeah I am still learning about all this my
understanding is they're two dominant languages in
India there's Telugu and Hindi and sometimes
you will see they'll come out in different
languages I'm obviously I'm seeing it with
the subtitles I can't speak either language
the only words I know are Nattu Nattu which
is the dance number the dance number in in the
middle of our RRR were Ram and beam do the not to
not to dance right then it turns into a dance-off
some people some friends of mine have recommended
RRR they they kind of cringe for a minute like oh
is it's one of those Bollywood movies with
dance numbers and I correct them because I
was corrected it's Hollywood the dance number
is a big part of the story it's a huge part of
the story so it's not just put in there just to
be in there right there's a purpose there's a
purpose for not to not to to be in the middle
of that and God I wish I had the skills that
those actors did in that scene it's really
remarkable so God just if I could say one
thing just go see RRR in the theater if you
have the opportunity you can thank me later.